A lot of things can be beautiful landscapes,
faces fine art or epic architecture,
stars in the sky or simply the reflection of the sun on an empty bottle,
but is nothing tangible.
It only exists in our heads as a pleasant feeling.
If we have to define it,
we perceive something as beautiful.
If it's color,
shape,
form,
or proportion somehow are appealing or delightful to us.
Beauty is a very human experience that's been with us for millions of years.
Even our first tools with trem two asymmetrical shape.
Researchers have tried to find practical reasons why our ancestors invested the
time to make that tools look nice,
but couldn't really identify any.
It seems that early humans shaped their tools into teardrops simply because they
liked them better that way.
Throughout our history,
the definition of beauty has changed.
A lot.
Ideals have shifted or turned into that opposite,
but beyond individual and contemporary tastes,
some things have never really gone out of fashion.
The golden ratio,
symmetry or fractal patterns can be found in the art and architecture of
cultures.
From our beginnings to today.
Humans seem to be in mysterious,
inherent agreement about the beauty of certain things.
The patterns that keep coming up are all rooted in nature.
They became part of our biology because they helped our ancestors survive.
Yeah.
[inaudible] patterns,
for example,
occur all over nature in snail shells,
flower heads,
waves or clouds.
Identifying and assessing these things and phenomena correctly used to be vital.
Do those clouds been rain will come soon?
Are these water's safe to swim through?
Can I eat this?
Another pervasive thing is symmetry in nature.
It means everything is as it should be,
stems and trees and leaves and blossoms or grow symmetrically.
The Dia with impressive antlers is probably a source of nutritious meat.
AIDS are formed.
Wheat here may not be safe to eat.
Asymmetrical face is more likely to belong to a healthy and fertile meeting
partner because symmetry is so common in fauna and flora.
It's extremely familiar to our brain.
It helped our ancestors evaluate their environment more easily and react quickly
to danger.
Things that help us survive,
activate the reward center in our brain,
recognizing signals of safety and nutrition trigger nice feelings in us.
So our sense of beauty probably evolved from pattern recognition,
but it goes way beyond that.
Now,
humans seem to have evolved an instinct for beauty that is deeply hardwired into
us.
It remains even after other processes in our brains stop working
Alzheimer's patients were asked to rank the beauty of several paintings.
Then the experiment was repeated two weeks later.
The patients long since forgotten the paintings,
but still ranked the beauty of the paintings in the same order.
One could argue that this doesn't say much,
so what if people stick to their personal preferences?
But other research has shown that we have a sort of lowest common denominator
when it comes to beauty.
In different experiments,
people were asked to distinguish real from fake abstract paintings.
Some were originals by Mondrian and Pollock that were painted based on strict
rules like fractal patterns.
While the invitations were not the majority picked out the original artworks.
This worked with paintings from both artists even though their styles are very
different.
Another experiment also used abstract works,
but ask people to pick them out among similar paintings made either by children
or animals.
Again,
the test subjects' pointed out the legit paintings whose patterns were Cafferty
planned and not random.
So while we have a hard time pinning down what beauty is or what is based on,
we somehow recognize it when we see us.
Humans don't navigate nature trying to survive day by day anymore.
We left the natural world behind and created our own.
We made the objects that surround us,
the things we wear and use and look at.
As we spread over the planet and our numbers grew,
we shaped a completely manmade environment.
In the process of doing so,
we often neglected beauty in favor of functionality,
cost or efficiency.
We built rows and rows of concrete housing blogs that nobody wants to live in.
We have ugly underground subway stations,
shabby public service buildings and sprawling malls.
One bland standardized box beside the next,
she winds don't like monotony.
Eye Tracking software has shown that people keep focusing on details and the
ordinance of architecture while brushing quickly over blank walls and not Tonia.
They know fun to look at.
They actually make us miserable experiments with skin sensors showed that
looking at vast dole facades makes us feel bored and uncomfortable.
This kind of boredom has been linked to raised heart rates and stress levels and
the opposite seems to be true too.
Over the last decades,
more and more studies have found that surroundings that aren't actually
aesthetically pleasing to us can improve our wellbeing,
our behavior,
cognitive function and mood.
Now bodies and brains react measurably and visibly to everything that surrounds
us.
Beauty in particular has such a strong impact on our wellbeing that making
useful things beautiful can actually make them better.
In 2017 a hospital examined recovery factors through observation and interviews
with patients and found that visual art in their lounge areas make them more
comfortable and happier about their stay.
In general.
Another study looked at how well patients recovered in a hospital that had two
worlds,
a very old and rather ugly one and a newly renovated ward.
To the researchers.
Surprise.
The patients that stayed in the new renovated environment needed less pain
medication and were released on average two days earlier than patients
recovering in the old ward.
More beautiful surroundings made them feel better physically,
but also has an effect on us on a daily basis.
It can improve our general habitats.
A study that looked at the main factors influencing the happiness of adults
revealed an unexpected result beside things like good health and a harmonious
family life.
Individual happiness is affected by how beautiful you find the city you live in.
Beauty scored even higher than cleanliness or safety.
So what can we learn from all of this?
We know that we humans have been fine tuned for millions of years to process
visual input and assess our surroundings.
It's just what we're programmed to do and we're starting to learn more about how
much beauty as a property is really influencing us.
Beauty meets and inherent need for meaningful information.
Maybe it will be worth giving it more space in this manmade world we have
created.
Okay.
This video was a collaboration with the creative agencies optimize to and wash
as a contribution to that upcoming beauty exhibition.
The exhibition will be shown at the Mark Vienna from October the 23rd 2018 until
March the 31st 2019 and the Mark Frankfurt from May the first until September
30th,
2019 if you want to learn more about the impact of beauty and see tons of
gorgeous installations and multimedia objects,
go check it out.